being with AI is going to completely
change what people can expect from
search we are grounded in the fact that
you know Google dominates this space I I
feel like a new race is starting
with a complete new platform technology
I'm excited for the users to have Choice
finally and a real competitive race out
there Microsoft CEO Sachin Adella
finally thinks he has what it takes to
make Bing happen and grab some search
engine market share from Google his not
so secret weapon this all started with
us an open AI coming together with
really a research agenda on moving uh
the state-of-the-art of AI forward
Microsoft is taking openai's newest
artificial intelligence model and
intertwining it with Bing's search data
so you can chat with the search engine
and get up-to-date information so the
entire point of chat GPT early on was to
just sort of show the power of the large
model and the conversational
intelligence we now have not only the
current information that you usually
expect from a search engine but you can
then have a full conversation around
that current information and all the
other information that came before on
top of the new AI chat features in bing
Microsoft is adding chat GPT like
features to its edge browser so I came
here to Microsoft's headquarters in
Redmond Washington to get a Hands-On
demo of the new tools and here nadella's
thoughts on AI
[Music]
the first big new feature Bing chat
Incorporated right into the front page
of Bing will be an ask me anything box
type in your query say the biggest
winners of the 2023 Grammys because I
did not have time to watch it and up
Pops your usual search results which
Nadella says has also been improved with
AI but more interesting is this new chat
box that will start typing out an answer
to the question as it answers it also
includes citations so you know where the
information is coming from it allows me
to then have a full-on conversation
around all the search data so yes it's
annotated it's about being able to
create even the links back to all the
Publishers so this is just search just
better the system took about a minute to
return a list of the top Grammy winners
not exactly fast but you can tell it to
stop responding then you can ask
follow-up questions like do you know if
Beyonce is touring if you're a Beyonce
fan you might want to hurry and get your
tickets before they're gone like Chachi
BT you can ask it non-search type things
too like write 10 questions for Sacha
Nadella about AI
what are the key features and benefits
of new Bing chat mode and how does it
leverage AI to enhance the user
experience it really is grounded in
search results and helps me have a very
contextual chat or to be able to get to
the right answers Sacha Bing said or AI
Satya said the new Bing chat mode
leverages AI to understand the user's
intent context you said context and
preferences to provide relevant visual
logical and actionable responses
but while these may seem like fun and
games in these demos there are of course
real misuses of this technology we have
a lot of practice uh in thinking about
safety AI is only good if it is being
used in the real world understanding
learning human preferences and our
intent is to do that which is to put
stuff out there with safety but at the
same time realizing that we are going to
have to think about safety as an ongoing
responsibility not a one-time
responsibility he also told me there are
guard rails in place to prevent harmful
content hate speech and more
the second big feature Microsoft Edge
integration the Microsoft edge browser
will now have a bing sidebar where you
can ask it to summarize a web page
you're on or ask it to generate text for
instance I asked it to so I want to
write about a letter to Sacha Nadella
thanking him for his time then I was
able to tell it I wanted it written in
an enthusiastic tone in email form and
short
it knows that's pretty good there's a
lot of fear that AI is going to take our
jobs replace us is that unfounded and
how do you think about tools like Bing
now and how we use it in the job market
like I I think of this as at the
foundational level going to help us do
our jobs better reduce some of the
drudgery in some of our jobs uh whether
it's in coding or in writing or in
automating workflow or searching for
information so at the fundamental level
I think we need a productivity boost I
feel it'll create more jobs the barriers
to knowledge work will come down so I
mean the unintended consequences around
labor market shifts are always something
we need to be mindful of but I don't
subscribe to this zero sum or one lump
of Labor fallacy and I think that we're
going to have new jobs get created and
more job opportunities and it sounds
like more time right for sure for sure
we Outsource some of this right I
outsourced some of my my question
writing to this freed up a little bit
more of my time to do something else and
but you're still in in the loop and
you're in charge because you will you
get to accept the draft that's kind of
one of the metaphors I have is pretty
much all computer interaction going
forward you'll start with a draft that
doesn't mean you don't get to inspect
the draft or prove the draft and
redefine or re you know and edit the
draft the question is which company will
write that draft for us will it be
Microsoft with tools like this or Google
which owns ninety percent of the search
engine market share and right before my
interview with Mr Nadella announced Bard
it's similar AI chat feature that will
come to its own search engine how are
you thinking about monetizing this the
last time I checked software I mean it's
a search was the most profitable
category uh there is on planet Earth so
therefore all I need is a few more users
uh and someone else that I'm competing
in has to keep all of their users and
all of their gross margin it's a lot I'm
looking forward to that so no plans to
charge for newbing it's really
advertising model all the way through
let's start there and if we if there are
other models there may be other models
but there is enough Surplus let me put
it this way there is so much Surplus
that goes to one place which I think
would be nice if it was evenly
distributed what about Microsoft Office
just stay tuned I fully expect us and uh
to introduce these capabilities quite
frankly across the length and breadth of
Microsoft what about this guy
oh you know it's sort of like it was
early and so we get to redefine it uh
for the AI age and it's going to be very
useful so is he coming back he'll come
back in a variety of different ways I
think I'm most excited about being as
the real incarnation of clippy okay but
but no actual like pop-up I think we
have much better design mechanisms to do
what clippy aspired to do back in the
day does clippy haunt your dreams not
really it's probably the thing that was
the most fun character Microsoft
introduced which you know think about it
right we have been on a 30-year journey
to perfect it so I'm excited to be here
in 2023 launching Bing with AI
foreign
[Music]